let's go to our next caller from the six
one two area code who's calling today
from six one two how are you David
this is uh Charlie calling from the six
one two area code hey Charlie what's up
key hear me yes I got awesome I am so
glad to be in touch with you I love your
show
listen do it all the time great way to
stay informed and get a good objective
vision which I appreciate my main thing
I want to talk wanted to ask you about
is with all the recent drama with
Elizabeth Warren and Bernie Sanders
going back and forth do you think
Elizabeth Warren is really very
compliant in all this because I kind of
feel like this is mostly being set up by
CNN as opposed to Elizabeth Warren like
pushing this story I feel like it's
mostly being pushed by CNN as an
organization to smear Bernie Sanders
listen and interpretations as of right
now I don't know which of these is the
most likely so let's go through the
three camps one camp is this is a
concerted effort that was planted by the
Warren campaign given to CNN they said
to CNN if you guys publish this article
Monday and bring this up on Tuesday
Elizabeth Warren will confirm that this
is what Bernie said and you guys are
gonna have yourselves a real interesting
story that's one write the coordination
between Warren and CNN every second
possibility that is that this is
something CNN genuinely dug up with
their four sources that they claim in
their article on Monday and that they
decided for their benefit because they
want to have an interesting debate
because remember this story broke the
day after the debate CNN said let's do
this in order to create controversy and
generate attention for the debate they
presented it to Warren and Warren either
truthfully or untruthful he said yeah
Bernie said the thing the third
possibility is that this is actually
something a concerted effort that was
given to CNN it could be by the DNC
could be by Warren could be by Biden in
the DNC who knows the idea being let's
run interference to stop the Bernie
surge Bernie of course taking the lead
in that important Iowa poll over the
weekend before yeah and that that's
another possibility here as well I don't
know which is most likely at this point
I just don't know mm-hmm definitely I
think I definitely want to stay in the
camp of people who still believe in
Elizabeth Warren I don't think she's a
terrible I don't think she's a bad
person I think she is definitely not as
good as Bernie Sanders but she I think
she's still a very respectable
politician and woman and I uh I respect
her a lot so it's just that's just
something that I've been thinking about
thanks for answering my question that
was a really good answer now let me ask
you this if you if you were to find out
that this was Elizabeth Warren's idea
who said over the weekend we've got to
do something about Bernie let's go and
give this to CNN would that change your
opinion over it definitely would it
would definitely lower it some but also
I believe that at this point in the
primary
she's only being beaten in Iowa by
Bernie Sanders any politician in that
kind of state where it's like your thing
about it it's like the most important
state to win look if some past elections
and all that and there's one person in
your way you got to get rid of them I'd
kind of understand why she would go to
that length but as someone who supports
Bernie Sanders over a little bit warned
it would definitely make me bump her
down in my list of choices yeah I mean
I'm hearing that from a lot of people
and it seems that too to whatever extent
Warren was involved this may actually
hurt her and again if the goal was to
support Biden by creating a controversy
between the two progressives it doesn't
matter if it hurts Warren because the
point might actually be just to get
Biden through to the nomination right
that's exactly the thing is that they
might be trying to pit the two
progressives against one another in an
effort to divide the progressive vote
and then suppress people to judge some
try to get more of his support back to
Joe Biden
take some nomination that's kind of what
I'm thinking it might be it very well
may and hopefully I mean by the time we
published this call we may even know
more about this I really appreciate the
call charlie
yeah thank you man all right to talk to
you likewise take care talk to you let's
go to a quick break if you're holding
don't hang up because we are going right
back to the phones in just a minute or
two